okay for folks who are joining this
livestream this is one of our internal
meetings about incremental language
development form of language so we have
a variety of topics for today let's
start off talking about around oh these
are okay so this is graphic design for
okay what does what does this one mean
so we have Jeremy with us to comment on
this oh yes so the last time we were
discussing both the design of the
stander ever this expressing the full
error and then the error in parenthesis
explaining only error on the last digits
so this one here means plus minus 23 on
the whole number yes I think this will
be like 0.23
I think that's missing a zero positive
20 sleep at him yeah yeah that's right
in this configuration it could never be
it has to be something which is to the
right of the decimal point
exactly yeah this could be 101 4 to 3
point 1 2 3 4 plus minus 0.001 to 1 0 or
something right but it can never be more
than 2 but those two digits might have
to be right shifted by giving a point 0
0 1 you get what I'm saying
yes can I can I type something different
here is this not is this just a fake
perhaps if if you change the previous um
yeah the previous I used to use percent
to increase the font size okay you're
something really weird Jeremy I think if
you change 23 to yeah
but that's never correct either that
couldn't be correct either right it
would have to be this because it's not
gonna it's got to go down to the last
digits of the first number right yes
okay so that's a real case yeah
okay so what I'm saying is if this was
0.33 three one eight this would end up
being point zero zero zero two three
exactly which I think it's fine this is
Mike along with us or not
no unfortunately he had an external
meeting to attend okay so you direct the
idea of having the other smaller than
the name I think this is nice nice we
roughly read on this last time this
implementation okay well I'm happy with
that
yeah okay now what's this case here yes
so these case would be again this case
the tooth to three should be a 230 for
example in which it's let's cut it right
right what are you saying it should be
here change that 23 to are to start
different some this one here to 3-0 yeah
exactly so this is the case in which we
are denoting the error on the last
digits because there could be many more
digits before the parentheses right as
opposed to this which is the absolute
error on the number exactly and how do
we distinguish one we're using this case
versus this case well that's a separate
question there the idea would be either
two Hoffa and around from or to have
something inside around but I would
prefer a neuron form so would i but are
we gonna auto switch because I mean if
okay what is I don't know the anomalous
magnetic moment of the electron
I don't know what I am you know well you
know why I'm picking that yeah just in
case could be the Avogadro's number
which is very much well okay so wait a
minute let's take what the heck how do I
get something reasonable with this okay
but that has more digits right yes
indeed so this is a number that could
have an error in the last 50 years oh
yeah I see a point that we could have by
default a typesetting that switches to
the parenthesis sensation for I think we
should yeah I think we should I think
that that honestly by the time this is
probably almost the extreme case by the
time it's zero zero I mean the
alternative for that one would be to be
clear on that one let's just write it
out the alternative would be on four to
three point three one okay one four to
three point three one eight and then
that would be plus minus no it wouldn't
be even through 182 will be 3 1 and then
1/8 plus minus 2 3 yeah right yeah so be
this
okay I wonder if we have any flat upper
ends the don't seem to that don't break
the well okay so now you're looking at
this yeah Jeremy has some ideas and
that's respecting you Father them I see
them explain these to me why do these
make sense I haven't seen these in books
but it's it goes in the same direction
of being flattered yeah I agree
that's where I started and I thought
ceiling floor wasn't the worst analogy
there
all right the plus/minus I don't know I
felt like there was some connection
there although I almost trying to expand
the connections well let's try to
understand it so let me just see just
kind of salt it kind of the top and
bottom end of that that range yeah right
does it make sense to be that way around
top to bottom as opposed to bottom to
top I put top first because the plus I
just read it plus minus so I see I see I
see it kind of works better visually
somehow it looked better this way - do
you think that there are flattered by me
come if we're drawing a character we
could draw a flat paren yeah although
yet the you know can't be so straight
that it starts to look like a digit
right but it probably could be
compressed a bit yes I mean even if we
went here I'm kind of curious what it
looks like if we go
[Music]
if that's small is that crazy
in other words if it matches the size of
the plus/minus thing some Saints are not
not crazy
although natural work
okay so let's go you know although I
it's good to judge things that real size
because it's the impression is way
different when you scale them up yeah we
could also sense of that I mean that
should be centered that should be pushed
up yeah that would help definitely
arguably it might be nice actually I
think that would actually look really
good and why are we not pushing this up
I don't know how do you know how to do
that visit there's a there's a way of
doing a nudge hmm why can't I select
that okay so this particular thing is it
control up arrow oh my god no definitely
not
I've heard something totally weird I was
interesting I know I did it something
that's um Mac thing
okay format or is it in third type
setting well it thinks now job Oh splat
well whatever okay I think this is gonna
work okay and my suggestion is that we
switch between these forms one
thousandth I think it looks personal
what do you mean sorry yes so the zero
zero or twenty three I think it looks
good still look good but more serious
perhaps a good switch right I think
that's some standard Michael would know
what it is for doing that but I you know
there'll be a break point and it's
probably you know maybe it's two more of
those I'm not sure and obviously also
the other degree of freedom is going to
scientific notation for the whole thing
all right I think we have a winner here
I really quite like this I mean that
this this particular notation you know
after the embarrassment of realizing I
didn't know how to read those those
numbers after all these years because
I've never actually used the last digits
of Avogadro's number this is very clear
I think in description - okay now I'm
wondering about this one yeah it's fine
it's fine actually I mean it's using the
same plus/minus convention but it just
doesn't parenthesized so it's all good
okay we got a winner there all right
should we go on to our next topic yes
okay yes so two things one I try to
write a ref page but this is quite
difficult to explain so yeah I remember
the problems we had with fold pair list
so this is kind of similar because we
need to request that the function
returns a list so the first two lines
are alternatives for explaining the main
thing places the eye
well it's not out of that whole thing
machine so the f of the eyes exam any of
the eyes exactly
I
form is better but I think it can be
made clearer though a case should be
cave superscript um there's a special
input thing for doing that in da key
tools um may a minute
what now I'm totally confused okay
the I cave element yeah imagine that the
second list so the third argument
started with her too so we would be
replacing the second element of a full
list by the second element of sorry by
the first element returned by F of a
sublist okay let me try one time here
okay
okay so we want to say
thinking okay I want to try doing this
with IJ dot dot may be a mistake but
let's just try it okay
okay evaluates f of e I II J dot dot dot
um
[Music]
No okay hold on evaluates
you
you
how about that gives a list where it
gives a list of the
I both avoid using mapping because there
is nothing nothing really yeah despite
the name yes yes okay but I don't want
to say replaces because
okay replace his parts
I want to say with replaces the elements
no replaces gives a list no I don't want
to say list twice you say replaces just
suggested does it in place what do you
mean it does use replace part into
running I know comes well let's see what
replace part says here a yield
rushon
that's decent what do you think
yes so the the only thing that perhaps
miss here is the fact that II i if is
replaced with the first of f of Alana
so di are replaced with the elements of
the list obtained by evaluating that
it's ordered right yes that's the thing
which is understood that's what I'm
saying yeah okay yeah this looks good so
the the function well I there's an
implementation in the external it works
also with the case in which the instead
of I and J we have lists so they
represent positions in something deeper
as I think I yeah I think it can follow
this model I don't own it is for now
yeah and you can remove the ending the
comments before okay and then this
officer gets changed I try yeah
yes let me try it in the external do you
have any examples here do two simple
ones
well those are perfectly sensible yeah
so it has to be examples that cannot be
easily reconstructed with nothing right
it's not there yet perhaps it's not
today
oh no say it
okay but I think a good example so the
other case we we need to do is the case
where there's a list of lists here right
I think the list of lists should go
deeper I think that should be multiple
places to apply the app I don't
understand I was thinking of a case in
which we want to act on a matrix for
example because we want to do this with
columns and rows okay okay okay okay
okay that makes sense but so for example
a sorting network would be a fold of a
subset map exactly fold list of a subset
map and that would be a good example to
show I think yes certainly this will go
at least in applications it may be a bit
complicated for basic example yeah it's
not a basic example these are good basic
examples I mean I think you could have
I think in addition to accumulate you
can have one that is just total well
though can you do that with a replace
part but total so so we need a function
that returns a list from a list right a
list of the same length exactly without
having to write append something said
that so these two are nice in that
respect and Genesis on the live stream
is suggesting replaces eserve isokay
with the corresponding elements of this
I agree that corresponding elements
would be useful here yes as in the
source they did a slight whirring
virtually in which they
is that useful to say subsets of parts
or is it not really useful but it's not
that useful but it links nicely to the
name so it may be good to have it fine
okay okay so so just to be clear this
function for example for our quantum I
mean I think the cases that are worth
showing here I mean one of our quantum
you know some basic quantum gate it's
probably worth showing
so some reversible logic gate I mean
that there's a for example I'm pretty
sure in the n cash book there's a
grotesque and protection of reversible
logic let's take a look
okay
so
so
so the point
is right so you can give a permutation
so for example in the subset map thing
what you would give let's just write out
what that looks like so for example that
would be a permutation that you give so
you can give abcdefg and then you give
two for one for example
that's confusing but I mean six for one
night yep missing
now you could also do that permutation
the only other way to do that
permutation would there is a permit
permutation function which would do that
I think is that true without having to
give the other elements as yeah this is
not completely trivial right is there a
way to apply the permutation to 3 1 to
those elements I don't think there is no
I don't think so
right so that's an example and I think
it's worth looking at some yeah let me
just send you this one and also send you
the page of the ankus book which talks
about a reversible logic because that's
basically talking about the fundamental
point there let me see you're taking a
boolean function of three variables yeah
okay so hold on a second so the typical
case there is you you're taking yeah so
in
I mean just to give it okay what you
want is the two poles okay here we here
we go
tuples 1 0 comma 3 ok
right so there's a function each each
one of the eight factorial possible ways
of rearranging those two poles
corresponds to a ternary gate I'm sorry
I thinking that the function permeate
with cycles would be able to do that
because the cyclic notation is able to
select a few elements without specifying
on the rest okay okay fair enough but
still this is a good example of the
general power of this function right now
I mean it's a little unfortunate that
you know a typical thing might be
something like this that would be a
reverse by the way I would recommend we
use in Reverse I would just use reverse
for the whatever the rotate left
probably requires a little bit more
thought than reverse right yeah and you
could just do reverse with two elements
to begin with to make it clear what that
does that it just flips them around yep
it's not obvious how you would do that
and I mean it you can do it with a
permutation thing and that should be in
properties and relations okay great
there is an issue here which I was
saying which is then this next comment
which is whether we allow expressions in
the second argument with other heads no
why would we want
well maybe useful somewhere but it's
problematic because first there is the
question of what to F if we extract
things do we fit an list or the head
that it had originally right head
matching or not right and the diff
second difficult question is what do we
do is holding two bits they must not
cross this bridge let's let's get this
thing enough just for list
okay yeah so that that works already in
there
Mexican and I resent more visit okay
alright should we go into the next
terminus so the next one is a double
suggestion one is the idea of adding an
option same test to the function subset
q intersecting q and this joint Q so
that they can compare their elements to
decide membership so I've added there
the list of other functions that already
take the same test option and I think
this is perfectly consistent with the
fact that for example the contains
family already takes that same test
option so intersecting Q
okay it just has it just allows to you
lists it's not a where arcs no but even
for example intersection is for our and
it does allow the option so I think for
consistency but this is reasonable yeah
nothing so okay yes but there is
something else so delete duplicates
these are another function that for
which it is important to have some tests
but it has it as an argument rather than
an option
I think we should allow the option as
well yes but through other cases right
then the main thing for me is that there
is also delete duplicate spy and because
it needs the F function argument it
cannot have this other one and so the
option will be very useful for there
fine then support the option also as a
courtesy in the loop duplicates we might
even not want to document it but then
delete duplicates by yourself to
documentation exactly and there is a
second part of this which is tolerance
so tells is asking for having tolerance
argument in delete duplicates so this is
the list of functions that take the
tolerance option which are all of course
very numerix oriented and there is a
group of them which take both same test
and tolerance which are the matrix
predicates so in a sense delete
duplicates would belong to this case of
taking both so what it means if it's
within the tolerance it's considered to
be a duplicate Zabeth right okay
yes there is a slight issue here with
discussing with Rob which is if there is
a matching so there are two numbers with
respect to tolerance which one do we
return or whether we return some sort of
canonical representative of the
equivalence class things that I
understand yeah right so so if there are
two numbers yeah if they're not exactly
the same number and you're deleting
duplicates and what will be the default
tolerance like for machine precision
there will be a tolerance if you've got
machine precision numbers I mean right
now let's just do this I mean if we say
one point two point one point one point
good and now we say delete duplicates of
that okay great now we say one point
plus two x dollar machine Epsilon
interesting so so the claim is that this
would now be if I did one x machine
epsilon here or maybe I do half a
machine epsilon there right that already
works
yeah so this is using same q and thank
you I think it has one bit of Poland
tolerance okay but what does it return I
don't know I mean the obvious
possibilities are first in the list I
think that's the right thing to do
I think almost anything else is going to
be a little bit crazy I mean the other
thing to do would be but it's crazy is
number with few or none that's crazy I
was going to say more round
but I think that's crazy yeah that's
probably unstable yeah yeah the first
one is probably a good idea mm-hmm okay
so that would be my suggestion okay okay
okay yes and the final thing is some
more open discussion
it's whether we can have a symbol any
representing any choice in a given
argument so for example this has
appeared in the discussion of how to
represent a race of any dimension so for
example in the last line race the first
argument represents the dimensions of
the array you are living with so how do
we represent all the race of any
dimensions but it still being symmetric
what's wrong with blank we could just
blank
yes but somehow blank seems like
committing to using the pattern matcher
so it's giving more power forward power
then perhaps it's needed there well the
question is is I mean I agree that along
with all none and so on any might be an
interesting thing to have all right
let's try to inventory whether there are
places you know I mean they're places
where we've probably used all where any
might actually be more appropriate
exactly yeah because sometime somehow
all means do you are considering all the
possibilities at the same time rather
than one of them right I think I
generally support the idea of
introducing this it would just be nice
to know where else we care about it
right exactly
okay so I'll try to mentor inventory
places where we could use it fine
okay all right okay mom so we went fast
today through that yunda right let me
let me ask about a couple of things here
just so-so around the around stuff is
all coming together yes yes we are
moving forward with it it's Brett
succeeding in supporting it in the
visualization functions yes they are
working on that and there are a few
options supporting it I think they are
called ever disappoint various forms
like pairs and errors and it's something
that lets plot on its own is going to
support or is it a newless plot it's
their options of the previous functions
that specify how do you want to support
it whether with a bar or arrows but
there's a default presumably in let's
plot that does something reasonable yes
yes wonderful okay okay
question for Sushma Sushma here yes all
the various things that are green
lighted and a steaming Ford are they all
steaming or have some of them run
aground no most of them are done and I
think waiting for things okay I've
marked his green lighted from a while
ago so basic code base decode those are
done right that was done under a
different name those were done but like
you know very yeah I think it was a
different name or something so as a
constructor which is done Green Tyson
curved
yes that's done that's done so actually
we should mark these in this notebook
and and move them over screen capture is
done construct is done what it contains
is this one I don't even remember
and we also it came that came in
discussion with construct and we did not
really green like that I think because
contains I can imagine that contains is
somehow related to it contains family
should be but yeah I don't know well
maybe you could tell find out okay
signed number form or was that something
which is going to be an option to number
form mmm you go check into that last
sign okay capitalized did we think we've
done this or not yeah we have the the
various forms they're the only pending
thing which was a lower priority is to
look at having alternative versions of
title casing so we have our primary
version of title case but there's AP
standard Chicago Manual of style I'm
gonna add that to my list of potential
student projects yeah it's something
that was on the agenda but we marked it
as relatively low for the moment but it
would be a good student project or
intern project okay
so eg ap style and so on yeah okay all
right I don't think that needs to be on
this list here for right now I mean it's
some okay normalized vector and vector
magnitude that was done wasn't it no it
is not done but it is in that non
project which is like actively being
worked on right now in LCC okay and in
my voice one is done is not yes right
away is done yes restart that is not a
function that I have been tracking but I
can check with Roman please do
yes channel receiver function did that
get done just a function is a function
yes it is great take list was done right
it's done yep January February I need to
take I don't think that was done decimal
form is done it's done system process
data is done
[Music]
sort of changing with that is not done
that is not done and that needs to be
pushed some more okay
scan index did we ever do that in the
end you know I think we should abandon
this it's I mean I'm not sure nobody
cares
okay so Sushma can you move these things
into the appropriate done and abandoned
notebooks and so on yeah so in third
place is a cesspool yeah we but it was
too big this is the sort of project
which is the size of of the predictive
interface or something that I'm not
clear it's worthwhile it would be
interesting if it worked but it's a lot
of work I'm adding that to my student
list for further exploration okay but I
would abandon it from here okay
all right that's those ones let's just
have a quick look through so okay so
semantics cases oh by the way are you
tracking and body simulation no I'm not
tracking that but I've been in a meeting
once because it's Rob's project and I
can ask information to quantity
manipulation supports there okay great
because that's important yeah okay okay
so we've got quite a lot of things here
which are like like this whole semantic
cases thing that's a machine learning
thing yeah we've discussed that in
machine learning meetings and I remember
Julia was supposed to look at image
cases part of it and it's where we
decided to start yeah I know but then
Jerome was supposed to look at the text
part of that correct yeah okay so that
one is Jerome is working on okay I have
no idea what multi resultant even is
okay this whole thing about delete
outliers is that part of what will come
out of the machine learning stuff it's
part of missing okay then can we please
make sure that these functions okay so
that is being worked on by Amir yeah I
mean I remember talking to both you and
Etienne about any 10 things that we can
include this in the missing imputation
projects but you were not very sure I
just want that particular wrapper the
delete outliers concept
which is not quite the same as missing
imputation of its different function it
might come out of the same algorithms
but it's a different function okay so
you want me to just mention that we need
this wrapper video make sure it's in the
machine learning agenda okay okay
host registration director I believe is
coming along have you been involved in
that that's a problem on the CSE meeting
yeah that is I can see me humming that
okay can you um check that please and
something added about who's doing that
this can of worms
any idea what's happening that's you two
in John's group okay okay clean dataset
well that has to do with you know that's
part of the data set development project
for which I think we I mean what's
happening with that is is is do we agree
Igor is gonna do that or what's the
story that with me right now and but I
don't have much time to put on it and
very important is to get increase for
example to working oh yeah that's right
we gotta get to work on sorry what were
we getting Igor to work on with this
cast about it but his manager thought he
had other things to finish first I'm
drawing my eyes but they okay fair
enough
okay but but the the story of getting
Chris to work on data set yeah when is
that going to happen
did he start looking at it at all
not because he's still here working on
the abort from alpha not books and
updating the packet of interface for
that but I think if we get the approval
from John fools it should be okay he was
interested in in dataset certainly let
me just um
okay array Association so that's my
plate as well also related to data sets
because it could save much space there
but no I'm not working on that right now
okay we might want to look at somebody
else taking a look at that
is that something Constantine could look
at perhaps perhaps I can I can ask her
me certainly this would be like a multi
dimensional form of Association which is
a concept that might be useful in other
places well but this is the thing that
wasn't actually stored as a
multi-dimensional Association was it
it's something that creates a structure
that is like a multi-dimensional
Association yes we have discussed both
concepts I guess I was talking about
Association array rather than our
association we have talked about both
things so this was the constructor how
did I call it thread Keith right or
something that yes you had other names
for it yes both both of these are are
useful yes
okay maybe we need a separate let's put
that on the agenda for another ILD
meeting okay this fine character
encoding ei is supposed to have done
this right yeah I mean it's it's
something that she's working for to us
but I thought that was okay almost about
to be done okay
session data or session information do
we explore that or not no it was it was
discussed and I think one of my MD or
else he's emitting I'm not quite sure
discuss that and we decided to make a
very basic implementation of session
information and to work on it but then
Luke
very different projects to work on so
that it's a bit stall for now but I can
push that I don't think it's that
important column map and those ones I
think that is worth doing where was that
in our last discussion I was trying to
convince you to have a second argument
map rather than all these new functions
I'm a bit worried of intuition so many
functions now I agree well let's bring
that back again we didn't come to a
conclusion last time right I mean the
last time you still wanted to have for
least separate functions but it's going
to be many okay fine well let's bring
that back again to another LD meeting
yes so we discussed about its extent and
we decided to have something smaller and
this is easily implemented I'm gonna see
whether we gave it to Constantine or
okay so you should check yes I mean if
he cannot do it I can do this whatever
happened to file partitions didn't we do
that I don't think so I think that is
that a CSV project I was told to send it
to CSC at some point and I did send it I
don't know if that was discussed in CSV
at any point but I think it was
discussed and I think we why don't she
determine what happened we might have
killed it I'm not sure that's one for
Roman could you determine that yes I was
okay this is all related to the geometry
project which by the way I wouldn't mind
seeing another update on but is this
actually in the geometry project or not
that's the change Jimmy and Rogers
project oh I mean I mean Michaels
Michael and James this project I see
them merging now I mean that they are
working imagine it now so that's great
mm-hm
that one is in progress now we just went
over that yesterday this one is now
eminently doable and we should just do
it that should be given to Garrett who
can get Sushma I'm sumon to do it okay I
mean it'll have a bunch of weird options
but but it's absolutely doable with the
web execute functionality make sense
okay Gio let's plot 3d that's that's on
you I think yes but this is together
with many other things directed to
elevations and 3d so there's got to be
another iteration of Geo
I'm working on other things now I know
this one is beautifully in progress
actually I'm gonna remove that from this
list because I think it's just not
useful to have it in this list you agree
yeah okay and it's certainly not
lowering the height of the the fruit is
variable in here okay
okay let's just look at a couple of
these and then we should wrap here
fraction form what did we ever do with
this and mixed number form I don't think
we dealt with either of those I mean
mixed number for me having worked now
for for sure we have something not
working on that we are trying to finish
percent form
it's like she's realized okay so these
are followings who is doing percent form
and then okay well maybe he could do
these after that yes yes okay so all
three of these need to we need to finish
design and get them ready for
implantation they're all sensible yes
yes it's more a matter of implementation
details I know right what was this one I
think we were thinking of
generalizations of power so in the same
way that we have power being the power
of times this may be power of other
products
because sometimes you can compute faster
than using a power tree or something
right that's the point yeah if it's
associative that's right if you know
it's associative you can use a power
tree to compute it right yeah that's
kind of interesting
well okay for a different time all right
I think we've got all we need here
um lots of good stuff I am keen to see
Krista start to work on data set by the
way sounds good okay
thanks to people on the live stream see
ya